just look at what they've done there it
is
confirmed by the official gdp data this
week
yet another disaster brought to you by
the establishment
the biggest economic collapse in
american history
yes china infected the world with its
virus they knew how bad it was but
covered it up
they stopped travel within china but
deliberately allowed travel
out of china until president trump moved
to shut it down
we talk about reparations and rightly so
not just here at home for racial
injustice but right now
from china to the world for their virus
crimes
china must pay for what their government
did
and the catastrophic damage they caused
but once the virus
was here the responsibility lay with our
leaders
and what a complete and utter mess
they've made of it
right from the start we told you the
truth about this virus
that most people have nothing to fear
that the right response
is to protect the vulnerable that the
mass shutdowns were a massive mistake
president trump he had the right
instincts too right from the start
but the media the medical establishment
the political establishment they
didn't have a clue fueled by
misinformation and hype
from the trump-hating media just as
we're seeing now with a brainless and
reckless obsession
with case numbers the doctors took to
the airwaves
to insist that everything be
subordinated to the one single objective
of trying to stop anyone being infected
what lunacy this was inflicted on
america
by a media medical complex in love with
a sound of its own
panic in the first world war the brave
soldiers sent to their deaths by idiot
generals
were described as lions led by donkeys
today with the doctors falling in line
behind the media deception
it's donkeys led by liars what on earth
were we doing
allowing the doctors to take over the
country
as the french philosopher and activist
bernard levy put it this week yes
america
i'm gonna quote a french philosopher at
you because this guy is bang on the
money
the doctors are just people they just
don't know
they cannot be invested with this
authority under their white coats they
are naked
like hans christian andersen's emperor
and like you and me people keep saying
this is an unprecedented pandemic he
continues
it is not true there seems to be an
intention a collective desire to panic
it's not as big a disaster as we think
there's a sort of unilateral focus covet
covert covid
it completely erased any other
information he says we must
resist the wind of madness blowing over
the world
yes we must because the cost of the
madness the human cost
is now astronomical and it's born not by
the doctors
not by their media fanboys and girls not
by the
clueless politicians making it up as
they go along
but mainly by the poorest americans
working americans black and hispanic
americans
the very people that the shutdown
fanatics say they speak for but
obviously don't
here's the shutdown toll over 17 million
still out of work at one point it was 40
million
over one thousand dollars per taxpayer
in government spending
over a hundred thousand small businesses
shut down for good and of course the
human toll
the mental health catastrophe and the
disastrous effects of long-term poverty
on life expectancy and what did it all
achieve
practically nothing you saw similar
death rates
in countries that had no shutdown and
countries that had even tougher
shutdowns
fauci says the virus spread because we
only locked down
50 percent of the country what so he
wants to see
80 million unemployed 200 000 small
businesses go bust
twice as many medical operations
cancelled twice as much domestic
violence
twice as much substance abuse twice as
much child abuse
haven't we suffered enough dr fauci what
is wrong with these people
they have no idea what they're doing
fauci is following an old playbook
for a different disease doctor death and
destruction
the cdc's robert redfield screwed up
tests for months
with his bureaucratic bungling vain
governors around the country luxuriated
in the limelight of daily press
briefings
where they ludicrously pretended they
could micromanage mother nature with
their absurd
phases and stages and gating criteria
what hubris
what arrogance what idiots
they told us how carefully they would
lift restrictions
then rip them off and threw them to the
wind when it was a political protest
they favored they told us it was all
about flattening the curve
without telling us that you end up with
the same outcomes regardless
we said from the start the shutdowns are
pointless
the virus will come back the minute you
open up
sure enough around the world cases are
rising
everywhere the lockdowns are being
lifted
it was all just an illusion there was no
governor in control of events those
carefully calibrated public health
strategies
designed by the experts to keep us safe
because as they never tire of telling us
safety is their top priority they were a
joke
ineffective counterproductive the worst
of them new york's cuomo
sent thousands to their deaths as a
conscious and deliberate policy choice
with his disastrous nursing home order
all in all
this is the biggest public policy
disaster
in history and still they press on
dementedly making it worse now we have
the stupid reopening rules the pseudo
scientific protocols and procedures
the pointless temperature checks the
time wasting health questionnaires
the random capacity limits 25
33 50 all of it just make
work nonsense from an out of touch
corporate and government bureaucratic
elite
sweep it away all of it reopen schools
reopen the economy everywhere
with one exception as we said all along
protect the vulnerable
to do that get the data on who is
vulnerable precise data based on who has
actually died
what exactly do we mean when we say
underlying conditions
it is a scandal a total national scandal
that we still do not have this
information
from fauci what has he been doing all
these months
apart from smugly lapping up the
adoration
of a laughably uncritical media and
after all this
guess who wants to give fauchi even more
power
that's right joe biden with typically
humiliating and craven pandering to his
media cheerleaders
biden confirms he'll make everything
even worse
with biden than the democrats there'd be
even more bogus bureaucracy
and shut down stupidity and that
terrifying prospect gets closer every
day
because of the baffling complacency of
the trump campaign
where's the energy where are the ideas
where's the hope for the future
two weeks ago we were promised exciting
policy announcements in the next two
weeks
we're still waiting here's this week's
campaign memo
you don't win elections with facebook
ads or digital strategy or whatever
sure they can help but you win elections
with ideas about the future
what you're going to do for people the
changes you will bring
we're not seeing any of that from the
trump campaign they seem to be
sleepwalking into a biden presidency in
the total calamity
of a democrat takeover house senate
white house the lot
unconstrained power to implement the
most left-wing agenda
ever put before the american people by a
major party
wake up we need to see a major trump
policy announcement or policy speech
every week
between now and november nothing else
will do
get on with it or the country is sunk
on coronavirus and everything else